Bonjour à tous, on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Je vais m'attaquer à un sujet assez sensible : la pornographie.
Je ne suis pas venu tout seul, je suis venu accompagné de toutes mes notes, de tous les documents sur lesquels je vais m'appuyer dans cette vidéo.
On va prendre le temps d'aller au fond du sujet.
On se retrouve tout de suite après le générique.
C'est parti !
Avant que les premiers commentaires ne fusent,
je précise tout de suite que je ne vais pas aborder la question de la pornographie sous un angle moral.
Tout simplement parce que ça ne me regarde pas, ça ne m'intéresse pas, je m'en moque totalement.
Chacun fait absolument ce qu'il veut.
Donc tout argument qui consistera à me dire que critiquer la pornographie, c'est être un réactionnaire, un conservateur ou je ne sais quoi, et bien, ça tombe à l'eau.
Ça ne fonctionnera pas, parce qu'ici, je vais m'appuyer sur des données factuelles, des données concrètes, scientifiques.
Toutes les sources sont en description de la vidéo.
J'afficherai également, au fur et à mesure, les captures d'écran
pour que vous puissiez aller vérifier et faire vos propres recherches sur tout ce que je dirai.
Avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet, je vous demanderai de partager au maximum cette vidéo autour de vous, sur vos réseaux sociaux,
pour que le plus de personnes possibles soient informées sur ce sujet complexe, parfois tabou, qu'est la pornographie.
J'en profite aussi pour remercier et pour rendre hommage au travail de Boris :
il a réalisé une vidéo très complète sur le sujet, dont je me suis, en partie, inspiré.
Je vous invite à aller la voir,
le lien est dans la description.
On y va, c'est parti !
J'ai organisé ma vidéo en cinq points principaux,
et je vous invite à rester jusqu'à la fin parce que, vous allez voir, on va y aller crescendo.
Premier point, quelque chose que vous savez tous mais qu'il est important de rappeler :
La pornographie, c'est d'abord de l'économie.
C'est une économie assez juteuse, sans vouloir faire de jeu de mots...
puisque ça rapporte environ 10 milliards de dollars par an, et 90% de la production pornographique vient des Etats-Unis.
N'oublions pas que s'il n'y avait pas de commerce de la pornographie,
il n'y aurait pas de pornographie.
Donc avant de dire que la pornographie est une forme d'art cinématographique ou je ne sais quoi,
non, la pornographie c'est d'abord une économie.
Autre chiffre intéressant : il faut savoir qu'entre 25 et 35% des requêtes tapées sur Internet sont en relation avec du contenu pornographique.
Ce qui veut dire que plus d'un tiers de ce que l'on recherche dans le monde sur Internet, c'est du sexe.
Ce rappel étant fait, on passe maintenant au deuxième point :
Ce deuxième point est évidemment en lien avec le premier :
si le porno est une économie, c'est évidemment l'économie du corps, c'est l'instrumentalisation du corps.
Et c'est une instrumentalisation qui est basée sur la plus grande ressource disponible dans le monde, une ressource illimitée, à savoir : le désir.
Dites-vous bien qu'un individu homme, de sa puberté jusqu'à sa mort, est en capacité de ressentir du désir sexuel.
Si vous multipliez cela par le nombre d'hommes qui ont accès à Internet sur terre,
et que vous multipliez ce résultat par le nombre d'orgasmes que peut avoir un homme par jour,
vous obtenez un chiffre assez... énorme.
Comme le rappelait Boris dans sa vidéo, ce sont les hommes qui se font le plus facilement mener à la braguette.
Et de ce fait, il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce que la pornographie soit, le plus souvent, la représentation de fantasmes masculins.
Ce qui nous permettra de mieux comprendre pourquoi la femme est instrumentalisée,
pourquoi la femme est objectivée dans les films pornographiques.
En cela, la pornographie, c'est d'abord
la mise en scène, à des fins d'excitation sexuelle, de l'avilissement des femmes.
Et peu importe que les femmes qui jouent dans ces films soient consentantes,
puisque la notion de consentement est d'abord une notion juridique.
C'est une notion sur laquelle repose un contrat.
Donc oui, on peut consentir à être déshumanisé, on peut consentir à être humilié, avili publiquement.
On peut même consentir à la torture.
On peut même consentir à sa propre mort,
puisque, rappelez vous ce fait divers dans lequel un homme a posé une petite annonce dans laquelle il demandait à être assassiné.
Ça fait partie des choses auxquelles on peut consentir, c'est vrai.
Mais ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a consentement qu'il n'y a pas déshumanisation.
Et entendons-nous bien, le problème n'est pas ici moral,
puisque, après tout, chacun fait ce qu'il veut dans le cadre de son intimité.
Le problème est que la pornographie est destinée à être exposée, à être représentée publiquement.
On peut aimer les pratiques sexuelles extrêmes.
On peut avoir envie de faire des choses hors du commun dans le cadre de son intimité sexuelle.
Mais ne soyons pas naïfs, la représentation de ce type de fantasme a d'abord une visée économique,
tout simplement parce qu'elle s'adresse aux plus bas instincts de l'homme.
Et tout le monde sait que si on met un cul sur une affiche, ça va forcément attirer l'attention.
Le problème, je disais, ne concerne pas les pratiques sexuelles extrêmes ou déviantes, qui relèvent du libre choix de chacun.
Le problème réside dans la représentation publique, dans l'accessibilité au public, de pratiques qui relèvent d'abord du cadre privé.
C'est la distinction que faisait le philosophe Nietzsche entre
d'un côté, le dionysiaque, qui est le monde de l'irrationnel, le monde de l'animalité, de la pulsion, de l'instinct.
et le monde de l'apollinien, qui est le monde du rationnel, du sens, des règles, des cadres.
Et à partir du moment où on mélange ces deux mondes que sont le dionysiaque et l'apollinien,
on est dans la confusion totale des genres, et on est forcément dans la perturbation des repères.
La pornographie, c'est littéralement la représentation de la prostitution.
Et lorsqu'on parle de quelque chose d'obscène, "obscène" veut dire "en dehors de la scène".
Ce qui est en dehors de la scène, c'est ce qui n'est pas censé être représenté, ce qui n'est pas censé être exposé aux yeux du public, et notamment de nos enfants.
Or le problème, vous le voyez arriver, c'est que, de fait, la pornographie, aujourd'hui, n'est plus un domaine séparé et réservé aux adultes.
C'est quelque chose qui peut être accessible à n'importe qui à partir du moment où on a une connexion internet.
Nos enfants, vos enfants, ont accès à la pornographie.
Evidemment, ils ne vous le diront pas, ils n'iront pas se vanter de consulter des images pornographiques sur Internet.
Mais dites-vous bien qu'à partir du moment où ils sont en âge de se servir d'un smartphone, ils sont en âge d'aller consulter des sites pornographiques.
Et ils le font.
Ils le font entre copains, ils le font dans la cour de récréation, ils le font dans leur chambre, quand vous n'êtes pas là ou quand vous êtes en train de dormir. Ils le font quand ils le souhaitent.
Et vous savez très bien que pour accéder à un site pornographique, il suffit simplement de répondre à la question "Avez-vous plus de 18 ans?".
Je peux vous dire que même à 13 ou 14 ans, ce n'est pas ça qui va vous dissuader.
Donc à ceux qui me diront "la pornographie a toujours existé", "ce n'est pas quelque chose de nouveau donc ce n'est pas quelque chose dont il faut s'inquiéter",
je réponds, oui, la pornographie a toujours existé. Mais les supports pornographiques qui existaient dans l'Antiquité, au Moyen Âge ou dans les années 50
n'ont absolument rien à voir avec les supports pornographiques actuels.
Puisque ces supports visuels étaient statiques, c'est-à-dire qu'ils consistaient dans des images, des gravures ou des dessins,
alors que les films pornographiques sont dynamiques, c'est-à-dire qu'ils mettent en scène des représentations en mouvement de l'acte sexuel.
Les représentations statiques de la sexualité, comme dans les vieux magazines tels que Playboy, ont pour effet de faire fonctionner l'imagination de celui qui les regarde.
L'image est un support mais l'imagination doit faire son travail pour qu'on puisse atteindre l'excitation.
Alors qu'avec les sites pornographiques aujourd'hui,
non seulement vous avez des images en mouvement, vous avez des séquences filmées, avec d'innombrables plans de caméras, qui sont autant d'occasions pour le cerveau de trouver une excitation ;
lorsque vous regardez un film porno, votre cerveau est beaucoup plus impliqué, il est beaucoup plus engagé dans ce que vous regardez que lorsque vous regardez une carte postale avec une femme nue.
Donc oui, la pornographie existe depuis toujours, mais ce qui n'existe pas depuis toujours, c'est le mode de diffusion dynamique de la pornographie que permet Internet.
Sachant qu'aujourd'hui, nous sommes encore devant un écran,
mais que très prochainement, l'écran va être remplacé par le casque de réalité virtuelle
dans lequel votre cerveau est incapable de faire la différence entre la fiction et la réalité.
Le cerveau réagit à ce que vous voyez, il réagit à un environnement sensoriel,
et le casque de réalité virtuelle va permettre une immersion sensorielle absolument totale
qui fait que votre cerveau ne va rien comprendre à ce qui lui arrive.
Le cerveau humain n'est pas conçu, il n'est pas prévu pour recevoir un flot d'images pornographiques aussi important.
Car c'est un point que nous allons aborder plus tard dans cette vidéo : pour le cerveau, les images que vous lui envoyez sont la réalité.
Donc quand on voit le déversement ininterrompu d'images pornographiques sur internet,
quand on sait que certains sites pornographiques contiennent plusieurs millions de vidéos à caractère sexuel,
on est loin de la rubrique lingerie du catalogue printemps-été de La Redoute.
C'est ce qui nous fait arriver au troisième point de cette vidéo :
Donc déjà, il faut savoir que la moitié des adolescents de 15 à 17 ans reconnaissent avoir déjà consulté un site pornographique.
Donc ça, ça ne concerne que ceux qui l'admettent. Imaginez la proportion réelle...
Et 14 ans, c'est l'âge moyen auquel un adolescent admet avoir consulté un site pornographique pour la première fois.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que parmi les adolescents interrogés, la plupart ont dit qu'ils se considéraient eux-mêmes trop jeunes pour regarder de la pornographie.
Et ils jugent, après coup, que cette expérience était prématurée.
Mais l'influence de la pornographie sur la jeunesse ne se limite pas à la consultation des sites pornographiques,
mais à la manière dont la pornographie influence la culture et notamment la culture des adolescents.
La pornographie influence la mode, elle influence le cinéma, mais aussi la culture musicale.
On retrouve l'influence de la pornographie dans les clips, notamment dans les clips de rap,
mais aussi dans l'hyper-sexualisation de nombreuses chanteuses qui représentent des modèles de féminité aujourd'hui pour les adolescentes.
Donc l'influence de la pornographie ne se limite pas à la consultation de sites pornographiques.
Elle se répand dans toute la culture populaire, à travers des codes, une esthétique et un langage.
Ovidie a très bien décrit ce phénomène dans une émission dont vous trouverez le lien en description.
Le porno influence la jeunesse, il influence nos représentations, il influence nos codes sociaux, culturels et linguistiques.
Mais il y a plus grave encore, et c'est le quatrième point de cette vidéo :
Alors là, on va rentrer dans les choses un petit peu sérieuses.
A tous ceux qui vous diront que la pornographie n'a aucun impact négatif sur la santé, à tous ceux qui vous diront qu'il ne faut pas exagérer,
qu'il ne faut pas dramatiser, que la pornographie n'a jamais fait de mal à personne :
figurez-vous que des études scientifiques ont été menées qui tendent à démontrer un impact négatif de la pornographie sur le cerveau.
La consultation régulière d'images pornographiques provoquerait un ralentissement de l'activité cérébrale et une diminution partielle de la matière grise.
Pour être plus précis, une exposition fréquente à du contenu pornographique engendrerait une diminution de la taille du striatum, une structure nerveuse située sous le cortex cérébral.
Comment cela est-il possible, me demanderez-vous?
Et bien, lorsque vous consultez du contenu pornographique, votre cerveau, soumis à l'excitation, libère une hormone : la dopamine.
Et évidemment, c'est mathématique, plus vous allez consulter d'images pornographiques, plus vous allez être soumis à l'excitation, et plus votre cerveau va libérer cette hormone du plaisir, la dopamine.
Au point de provoquer un dérèglement de ce qu'on appelle le système de la récompense.
Le système de la récompense, c'est très simple à comprendre :
c'est ce qui, dans notre cerveau, va faire qu'on associe un geste ou une action, à un plaisir, à une sensation agréable, à une récompense.
C'est ce qu'on utilise, par exemple, pour le dressage de certains animaux :
on va donner un sucre à un chien parce qu'il aura obéi, et donc on va l'inciter à reproduire le même geste.
On va donner du poisson à une otarie qui aura fait ce qu'on lui demandait.
Le système de la récompense, c'est tout simplement cette fonction cérébrale qui associe une action à un plaisir.
Et ce qui se produit quand on regarde régulièrement des images pornographiques,
c'est que le système de la récompense est activé en permanence.
Et donc le cerveau se retrouve totalement inondé de dopamine, il se retrouve inondé de plaisir,
et il ne comprend pas ce qu'il lui arrive, puisque normalement, la sensation de plaisir, c'est le résultat d'un certain effort.
Puisque, précisément, il n'y a de récompense que lorsqu'il y a eu un effort pour obtenir cette récompense.
C'est ce que le philosophe Jacques Derrida, a appelé la "différance",
c'est-à-dire que le plaisir est toujours différé par rapport à l'effort qui permet d'obtenir ce plaisir.
Pour en revenir au système de la récompense et à l'altération de l'activité cérébrale,
dites-vous bien que la sur-stimulation que provoque l'exposition massive à du contenu pornographique
va avoir pour effet de détruire progressivement vos connexions neuronales, et va complètement fragiliser votre centre de la décision.
Ce qui va avoir pour effet mécanique : une baisse de la motivation, une diminution de l’énergie, une diminution de la volonté,
une baisse de la libido aussi, voire un risque d'impuissance, puisqu'une sur-stimulation par la pornographie va altérer vos récepteurs sensoriels, va vous désensibiliser en quelque sorte.
Et c'est ce qui va donner, chez de nombreux consommateurs de pornographie,
un ramollissement de la volonté, une baisse du caractère, une baisse de l'énergie, une perte générale de l'envie, une tendance à l'isolement, à la procrastination, une fatigue chronique...
Et plus vous allez être à la recherche d'images extrêmes, d'images de plus en plus choquantes,
tout simplement parce qu'il existe ce qu'on appelle la neuroplasticité, et que le cerveau s'adapte et se conforme à ce que vous lui faites subir.
Voilà pourquoi plus vous allez être exposés à du contenu abêtissant, voire abrutissant,
plus vous allez perdre vos facultés intellectuelles, plus vous allez perdre vos capacités cognitives, vos capacités de réflexion.
Donc vous voyez qu'on aurait tort de prendre à la légère ce problème de la pornographie chez les jeunes.
Et cela me conduit maintenant à mon cinquième et dernier point :
On va sortir de l'hypocrisie et reconnaître que la pornographie est d'abord quelque chose qui est fait par les hommes, pour les hommes, en vue d'une jouissance sexuelle solitaire.
Ce n'est pas moi qui le dit, c'est l'actrice pornographique Tiffany Hopkins, qui a déclaré :
La masturbation est une étape dans la découverte par l'adolescent de sa sexualité.
Et il ne s'agit en aucun cas d'émettre un quelconque jugement moral sur cette pratique.
Par contre, il faut être conscient que comme le tabac, comme l'alcool, ou la drogue, la masturbation et la pornographie peuvent avoir un caractère addictif.
Lorsqu'un adolescent éprouve le besoin d'aller quotidiennement sur un site pornographique et de se masturber, c'est qu'il y a un problème.
Cela signifie que son système de la récompense est déréglé.
Cela signifie qu'il est en train d'instaurer une confusion dans son cerveau entre la réalité et la fiction.
Et cela va le conduire dans un cercle vicieux où pour échapper à la frustration de la réalité quotidienne, il va se réfugier dans les images pornographiques.
Et progressivement, son cerveau va s'adapter à cette nouvelle réalité virtuelle, donc à cette réalité qui n'en est pas une.
Ce qui va avoir un impact négatif dans l'ensemble de sa vie : sociale, sentimentale, et scolaire.
Un adolescent ou un jeune adulte qui est dépendant, qui est accro à la pornographie et à la masturbation
est un adolescent qui est en train de jeter totalement son énergie par la fenêtre, qui est en train de gaspiller toutes ses ressources.
Et plus il gaspillera son énergie, moins il aura envie d'entreprendre, moins il aura envie de réussir, moins les choses auront d'importance à ses yeux.
Et cela peut être la cause d'un isolement social, d'un échec scolaire, ou d'une frustration sentimentale.
Si tu regardes cette vidéo et que tu es dans cette situation, je t'encourage immédiatement à arrêter toute cette merde.
Tu as beaucoup mieux à faire dans ta vie que de te tirer le manche pendant des heures devant des femmes que tu ne rencontreras jamais.
Donc si tu as de la frustration, investis cette frustration dans quelque chose de productif.
Mets-toi au sport, inscris-toi à la salle, va faire du roller, va courir, va faire du foot avec tes potes.
Mets-toi à la musique. Mets-toi à la photo. Fais des vidéos.
Fais tout ce que tu veux,
mais fais quelque chose de productif.
Fais quelque chose dont tu pourras être fier.
Fais quelque chose qui va occuper ton esprit et ton temps.
Fais quelque chose qui a de la valeur.
Quant à vous, parents qui avez des adolescents, prenez conscience que ce problème en est un.
Ne sur-dramatisez pas le problème et n'essayez pas de confondre votre enfant si vous le soupçonnez de consulter des sites pornographiques.
Le but n'est surtout pas de l'humilier ou de le faire culpabiliser, cela n'arrangera absolument rien.
Sachez que le problème n'est pas irréversible, puisque la neuroplasticité du cerveau fait qu'il est très bien capable de se reprogrammer, de se réadapter.
Et qu'à partir du moment où on arrête de consulter du porno, il suffit de quelques jours, éventuellement de quelques semaines, pour que tout se remette en ordre.
Voilà ce que j'ai à vous dire : soyez vigilants soyez attentifs, et faites au mieux dans l'intérêt de votre enfant.
Voilà, cette vidéo est à présent terminée. Je vous remercie de l'avoir suivie jusqu'au bout.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner, de me rejoindre sur Facebook et sur Instagram.
Et un grand merci à toutes les personnes qui me soutiennent sur Tipeee, un grand merci à vous du fond du cœur.
Je vous dis à bientôt, pour une prochaine vidéo,
et d'ici là...
Soyez sages !